hello and welcome to
our daily online press briefing
online and live on ebs today is friday
the 21st
of may you just heard
commissioner behind us here to talk
about the provisional political
agreement
on the eu digital kovid certificate and
we will also have
an off the record technical briefing on
the same topic
immediately after this so we will aim to
keep this briefing
as short as possible and maximum
half an hour also because the
global health summit in rome has started
and
is broadcasted broscat live on ebs plus
and also because there's another press
conference that of the eurogroup
that will start at around 1pm so we know
that there is a lot
of competition today let me give you an
overview of the president's agenda for
next
week on monday and tuesday president
vandalian will participate
in the special meeting of the european
council
on wednesday she will chair the college
meeting as
usual then on thursday the president
will take
part in the eu japan summit via
video conference and later on the same
day she will chair a meeting with the
advisory panel on
kovid 19 also via video
[Music]
here
hi hello eric do you hear me yes go
ahead martha
hello i would like to ask ask about
immigration problems in safety
i would like to know if a european
commission
is prepared to commit european
funds for example if morocco don't
collaborate in
in the immigration regulation
is it correct would you do something
like that
would you talk to morocco
i i don't know just yes to ask them to
collaborate
and if he doesn't do it would you i mean
do any change with the
funding for example thank you
i think this uh would be a
question for nagila um
but i think it's a quite hypothetical
question as you know
uh contacts are ongoing with um with
morocco
on this file but i give the floor to
nabila nevertheless
um hello marta
thank you for a question what i would
like to do is
first of all remind you of yesterday's
tweet of the hrvp where he
was basically you know that the hiv
spoke yesterday with
a foreign minister of morocco where he
they had an honest discussion
about the situation in siwata and also
um now the idea is to um
uh to to discuss the the partnership
between
uh eu and morocco um for the moment we
see that the situation in seota
is uh uh
is a commodity i i have it in french
rather than in english but
the situation is is handled in siota
but when it comes to the fundings that
you were talking about this is not
something that was discussed
by the hrvp with with the foreign
ministers
thank you very much nebila are there
other questions on the issue
of thorita and relations with morocco
that is not the case are there other
issues for us today
before we move to the technical briefing
which admittedly
is definitely the main subject of the
day
yes i see a question well
regarding the eu another parliament
uh decision yesterday not to
sort of to freeze the the kai the
investment deal
so i just i'm wondering that uh
the chinese foreign ministry spokesman
today said
this is a win-win deal they always say
you know it's not a gift to
from one side to the other so i'm
wondering that
whether the commission is pursuing
uh sort of a behind-the-scene diplomatic
talks with the chinese side in order to
break
this dilemma thank you
thank you very much i will give the
floor to um martha in a second
uh amelia i'm sorry for without light on
the issue
um in general but obviously we do not
discuss
diplomatic contacts that take place what
is absolutely clear is that the
commission
as you know has
supported this deal and continues and
continues to do so but the executive
vice president has explained the
situation
that we are in and i will let miriam
explain
what is the state of play on this
yes thank you so we take note of the
parliamentary vote that took
yesterday which confirms that the
ratification process of the agreement
with china of the kai
should be seen in the wider political
context
and that these chinese regulatory
sanctions that are targeting some
members of the european parliament as
well as a whole parliamentary committee
are regrettable and do not create the
moment
for the moment the federal environment
for the ratification
having said that the agreement has not
been presented yet for adoption and
ratification
so we will reassess the situation once
the technical work which we are
currently undertaking the legal review
and then this will be followed
by the translations is completed
in general we continue to think that the
kai would bring benefits to europe and
to the european companies
in terms of market access in terms of
level playing field
and also in terms of sustainable
development in short we believe the kai
is in our interest
but what is clear however is that the
economic interest will not prevent
us as european union from standing up
for our
values and human rights including where
necessary through sanctions
thank you very much miriam are there
other questions
on this issue or on other trade related
files
for me i am today
that is not the case i open
for other issues
i do not see any other questions so we
will
close the midday briefing now move
straight to
the technical briefing on the digital
eu digital kovid certificate
in a few minutes thank you very much and
see you wednesday for the college
readout